in today's money watch we are talking
about so-called estate planning it is an
important topic and it is a topic for
everyone no matter your age or whether
you have a partner or children if you
have stuff this is for you according to
a recent survey though only about half
of people think that estate planning is
even at least somewhat important and
only about one in three have a will or a
living trust in place CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
what you need to know good morning learn
something already everybody has an
estate it's just your stuff yeah that's
it we we all have stuff and there are
three essential documents that make the
passing of your stuff and your wishes a
lot easier the first is a will just says
hey here's my stuff here's who it goes
to okay in that will you get to name
Guardians for your young kids so if you
don't have a will guess what happens the
state where you live decides who gets
your kids some of your siblings might be
great parents others not so much you
then have two other documents that are
really important one is called a
healthcare proxy I think this is vital
we just went through a once in a century
pandemic anyone can get sick at any time
you want to make your wishes known you
name somebody your agent who makes a
health care decision on your behalf and
the last document is called a power of
attorney and this could be important if
like gosh I tripped on the street and
I'm laid up in the hospital and I need
somebody to enroll in my benefits for me
so you're naming someone an agent to
make a business decision a transaction
all of these documents they have to be
in writing they have to be notarized so
no writing it on a napkin but I think
people are reluctant a because no one
wants to think about death even though
it's going to happen to all of us nobody
wants to think about it and you also
think if I don't have a lot of stuff if
I don't have a lot of money why do I
need to have an estate plan right and I
think you say to both of those well the
most important thing is that we do all
have stuff and it may not be valuable
but it's valuable to someone in your
family so it could be that you know for
me the most valuable thing in my
father's estate when he died nine years
ago was his trading badge from the
American Stock Exchange it's a piece of
plastic it had meaning to me I want that
and I had it and it's great but what I
think is important about having this
this this actual instruction manual is
it makes the disposition of your assets
easier but it also makes the process of
settling in a state much easier if you
die without a will you are called
intestine and that means that the
Probate Court kind of administers stuff
and they get to decide yes and and it's
usually a preset formula so it could be
like your parents it might be your
siblings but again some people are more
able to handle these responsibilities
than others settling in a state going
through probate it's not a pleasant
process but when you have a road map it
is much easier and it helps avoid family
conflicts think of all the stories we've
heard about oh my friend's cousin
doesn't speak to her anymore grandma
looks apart right and so that's why
another reason we want it down in
writing now some people might not have
stuff but they might have bad stuff what
happens to debt that's a great question
so the way we think about in this state
is you have your stuff or your assets
and then you have your liabilities your
debt and if you have enough ass sets to
cover your debts they get paid off after
you die if there's not enough money to
cover those debts those debts vanish
with the biggest with a big exception
hold on okay they don't go to the kids
no because the big issue is if you have
a debt that is co-signed or you have a
mortgage a co-borrower that debt will
not go away but if you had a student
loan and you die and there's not enough
Assets in your estate to pay off that
student loan that student loan will be
relieved gotcha all right so you can't
write it on an app you're gonna have to
hire a lawyer that is an obstacle for
people is there a kind of free is there
a quick we only have 15 seconds like a
quick website or something so there are
online resources a lot of them are free
and you should just check that out and
if you have a complicated case a second
marriage you have a lot of money you're
a partner and a firm you should probably
see a lawyer and it will take some
planning sales lessons here you're the
best we appreciate you